conan you're coming to los angeles
and they're building your studio in
universal city
a bleak pit of despair that will crush
your soul daily
and to get away from that and rejuvenate
you're going to want to come
here to sunny burbank california
[Music]
conan you're such a history buff we all
know that and to scratch that itch
you're going to want to come here to the
burbank historical society i'm in front
of the menser
house this is built in 1887 a year
before the jackpot for murders
five years before the beatles first lp
so let's go inside
and let's learn about burbank so i'm
talking to mary jane strickland who is
the founder
of the burbank historical society you
know burbank inside and out
so what what i'm wondering is you know
conan o'brien has a very distinctive
look i mean
some would say compelling some would say
freakish
he has very very distinct hair and i'm
just wondering
will the residents of burbank kind of
embrace that like have they seen
anything like that before would they be
okay with him what do you think
yeah we have a lot of people with funny
hairdos in burbank and
we think he's very handsome oh nice yes
so people in burbank find conor that's
good to know yes
nice conan i'm standing next to a holy
relic this is the jacket of johnny
carson someday
if you shrink eight inches and gain
some talent
this will adorn your torso
oh it burns it burns
hi i'm in a uh recreation of a 1900s
burbank home i am here in my parlor
with my wife opal who has gone
insane hopefully
opal i know you can hear me we're gonna
take you to the nervous hospital now
opal
you'll stop seeing those laughing ghosts
that force you to draw pictures of
swords that look like penises oh
by the way i just wanted you guys to see
this when you shoot stuff in la
even if it's something stupid like what
we're doing right now they assign you a
cop
a cop has to be there for security look
who they gave me
they gave me a friggin superhero look at
this guy what's your first name
jammer gamer more like you know what
gamer man that's who they assigned to me
gamer man
he's made of pure quartz and tornadoes
he's made of five
tornadoes good god in heaven my pleasure
sir
no hey my pleasure
and there's so many great business names
here in burbank like
hollywoof dog grooming hair to please
victorian heritage and don't forget the
business names that sound great when
said by jerry lewis
like dalson building boysen plaza
chadakatai and old navy
this is carrie height she's the owner of
the wax poetic beauty salon right here
in burbank
where i come to get my hair done
wax poetic uh conan is where you can
come not only get your hair done
uh you can read a book oh britney you
can look at art
admire but you know what why should i
talk about it when i can show
you what a day at wax poetic salon looks
like let's go check it out
[Music]
do you like paintings by serial killers
then come next door to hyena
and nothing says john wayne gacy like a
clown in a graveyard
and at hyena you can get all kinds of
decorations for
christmas easter first communion
hanukkah oh my goodness i just finished
another delicious lunch here
at the olives bistro inside the coast
hotel but what made this lunch
pretty amazing was i was served by the
restaurant's manager
rob lamberin better known as
robzilla competitive breakdancer
you're a competitive breakdancer and
you're world class
you go up against germans czechs chinese
and
russians everything you take them all on
17 years
17 years 17 years so you manage a
restaurant to pay for
the break dancing that is dedication if
you don't mind
i'm going to finish my coffee you're
going to bust some moves
it helps it helps with my digestion yes
[Music]
sir
[Music]
glorious well it's been an amazing day
here in burbank
i'll bet you can't wait to get here uh
it's time for me to scoot
gammer let's go home
[Applause]